and we continue our series in your
neighborhood and this morning
nate has taken us to the far northwest
valley but this time nate's not going
centennial bowling he's doing centennial
other things nate is exploring the
neighborhood of centennial hills
in the far northwest valley where the 95
meets the 215 up at the centennial bowl
yes and he has showed us a bunch of
stuff this morning let's check back in
with nate what you got going on there
good morning
hi john hi alex well even outside the
building i'm doing my best to wrap the
golden knights because they've got a win
tonight but here we are
in a village called centennial springs
it is tucked away in a cozy spot that is
east of the 95 freeway and
south of durango and farm road
even though norman rockwell lane where
we are is only a couple of blocks long
there's as much going on here as any of
rockwell's famous paintings of americana
from restaurants and residential to new
mixed used construction
there's also a park at the end of the
street named after one of the most
prominent citizens of the early days of
las vegas
cp pop squires many of the buildings
here have businesses at the street level
and apartments in the upper floors
yeah really a cool little spot here so
the park is just at the other end of the
street
but as all of southern nevada works
through the pandemic
we found one spot in the far northwest
that is really working to bring the
community together
the city of las vegas community center
and ymca
inside this building there are swimming
lessons for preschoolers tai chi lessons
for seniors and just about everything in
between
layna sloane says tai chi is just right
for her
as i've gotten older it seems like the
the kindest exercise as the body ages
it has a lot to do with inner strength
and i think that is important right now
she showed off her practice sword said
the master even suggests a fan that
could be used for self-protection in
addition to cooling off
then celia mori comes to the y for two
reasons
they offer child care for my little one
while we
parents work out and we are doing swim
lessons twice a week as well he's not
crying with the child care i'm surprised
and
i looked in the windows and he was
dancing with everybody and celia thinks
everyone's starting to see
light at the end of the pandemic tunnel
we go to a lot of the city parks
the centennial hills park has a splash
pad which we've been going to
and parents do socialize and talk her
almost two-year-old son tom
was also feeling social can you wave
high